pour le moment les chéris agathe alors
vous êtes revenu sur ce sur eux c'est
éric hémar exactement vous étiez chez
thierry ardisson samedi et il ya eu un
petit épisode savais pas que ça ait pris
une telle ampleur aimerait d'histoire du
culotte gates alors on va revoir on
revoyait extrait ou pas bah oui oui bah
oui comment d'un gatti salariale dubawi
way s'est levé une reconstitution en
direct et donc thierry ardisson vous a
posé la question sur le cloud gate bien
sûr tout le monde en a parlé un ca fait
les gros titres de la presse mais
malheureusement oui française
internationale regarde le culot de gueye
à l'esam au calcul guette les réseaux
sociaux se sont enflammées lors pas
grand chose ou bien parce comprendre les
gens écoutent oui bah si c'est que sur
twitter c'était des réactions de style
quelle grosse [ __ ] est fait exprès de
montrer sa culotte à la télé va envoyer
ça pour déconner j'ai trouvé un second
pauvres à ce moment ouais agathe de
power
ça vous appellez cette affaire mais oui
et d'ailleurs j'ai une théorie là-dessus
parce qu'on a fini par me l'expliquer -
effectivement donc la culotte elle a
paru chez pas peut-être un dixième de
seconde à la télé mais ça suffit pour
faire des captures d'écran et les filles
sur twitter se sont déchaînés en
m'accusant d'avoir montré ma culotte
exprès d'accord non pas du tout et on
m'a expliqué qu'en fait beaucoup des
téléspectatrices son amoureuse de vous
dans cyril et on pensait que je faisais
extrêmement évacuer la direction de la
prison raison je vous le dis je mourrais
mais je ne suis pas là pour montrer ma
culotte et je les regrettés cyril le
sait combien ça marche l'important c'est
que vous ayez une culotte et ça c'est
très important
bravo à vous et on ne le dit jamais
assez merci